Hi! Bill Nye here, explaining evolution with Emoji.
Take a look at this one: it's a molecule, and molecules just happen.
Look at any asteroid.
It's loaded with amino acids: a carbon, an oxygen and an oxygen.
Well somehow, probably with energy from the sun, these molecules hooked together...
...and accidentally found ways to reproduce themselves,...
...the same way crystals reproduce if you leave them alone for a while.
Anyway, these self-replicating molecules could not make perfect copies of themselves...
...and the imperfections that helped them make more copies stayed there,...
...kept getting reproduced and reproduced and reproduced.
And pretty soon, you have complicated things like bacteria...
...and then you've got multiple bacteria,...
...becoming multiple multiple multicellular organisms like poison ivy plants,...
...and barnacles and sea jellies and even my old boss.
And the key to this is time.
Time, time, time.
People used to think the Earth was a few thousand years old,...
...then they realized it was at least a few hundreds of millions of years old.
Well now, using radioactivity, we can tell you that the Earth is 4.54 billion years old.
A lot can happen in four and a half billion years.
Get a mirror.
Take a look at yourself.
We are all the result of evolution.